[Music]
strong guys
beautiful girlfriend
sorry i'm late i was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again kiss me like you miss me red
what in the [ __ ] is this
an inch cable
i'm here for the kid
what the kid
move or died
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be
you need you
you're a lot smarter than i look
i ain't letting cable kill this kid
but i can't do this alone can you speak
up it's hard to hear you with that pity
dick in your mouth
we're going to form a super duper
[ __ ] group made them tough
morally flexible and young enough to
carry their own franchise for 10 to 12
years it will be known as
x-force isn't that a little derivative
you're absolutely right
now let's go get our [ __ ] on
don't call it a comeback i've been here
tell me they got that in slow motion
doing the right thing is messy
but if you want to fight for what's
right
sometimes you have to fight dirty
that is why sisterhood of the traveling
pants is pure
pornography oh god i wish i finished
college
it lives up to the hype plus plus [ __ ]
it they probably won't even make a three
yeah why would they stop it too you
killed it
[Music]
i was born into war
bred into it
people think they understand pain
but they have no concept of it
what's the most pain you've ever felt
maybe the kind that leaves you more
machine than man wait no stop
what in the actual ass
dale why why why are the visual effects
not done it's a metal arm it's not like
we're trying to remove a mustache
ah [ __ ] it i'll do it myself
i'm cable and i'm from the future and i
like blowing [ __ ] up
reach for the sky
oh no sheriff deadpool you know you're a
lot taller shut up you little [ __ ]
take this oh regeneration powers
activate that's not something you said
cable i got the stones to help you
no biting
they're done already
oh wow that was unrealistically fast
okay
hit it
your time's up you dumb [ __ ] well
that's just lazy writing
[Music]
hello there welcome back i'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and run all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me i have my regular old
canvas here wet and ready to go
now let's grab our trusty two-inch brush
here
whack that off real good just beat it
like it owes you money we're gonna get a
little dab of our yellow snow here we're
gonna mix that with just another little
dab of our betty white
now let's just
dance in a happy little sky and remember
this is your world you get to make and
break the rules here
sweet baby jesus
wish i could jump in there and roll
around and all that cascading white
powder yeah just get high in all of
life's splendor
god i love cocaine
so much
holy [ __ ] knuckles i am high as a kite
right now
okay let's paint in a few little happy
trees there nothing wrong with making
friends with trees now what you don't
want to do
is eat these paints trust me on this one
all right i'm gonna whack off again
that's right
that feels good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting
so from our family to yours keep your
pants dry your dreams wet and remember
hugs not drugs
[Music]
do no such thing
[Music]
not on my watch
[Music]
[Music]
you're not
oh
[Music]
give me your [ __ ] wallet
[Music]
[Music]
no okay
no just tell him wade called thank you
wow nice suit zip it stanley
[Music]
oh jesus
oh
that's not good
no no no
oh you're not gonna walk that one off oh
that's so gross
ah
i'm so sorry
you know i i spent way too long in the
phone booth
if i'm being honest with myself i
probably should have just called 9-1-1
well
none of that matters now
because i think we're both
missing the real point here
ah
the [ __ ] is a phone booth doing on a
street corner
those disappear in 98
i suppose i could have just used my cell
and cherry garcia ice cream
you can eat this don't answer now
just rest
i mean actually i made a call goes to
the costumer his name is laird he
usually helps me put the suit on
i don't know how the other guys do it so
quickly you probably wouldn't be dead if
it was logan
because he gotta change into
i wears a [ __ ] tank top and a pair of
jeans
ah brazil
the beautiful sun-kissed home of pele
hairless genitalia and the world's
largest jared leto statue
to show my dedication to the legions of
brazilian deadpool fans i've spent up to
20 minutes on google translate as well
as countless hours watching telenovelas
to teach me everything about your
official language that's right brazil
this sexy red spandex ass learned to
speak portuguese
all right well hopefully
i get the accent right here it goes
is
look me straight in the nipples and tell
me i didn't just nail that
now what are you waiting for go to the
website below to preserve your spot and
you're sure to be the talk of sao paulo
space is limited so best hurry because i
think we can all agree there's nothing
like a wild day or night in brazil to
make a special memory that you'll
cherish forever
just ask the 2016 u.s men's swimming
team
just kidding
they'll probably make some [ __ ] up ciao